هلا نايف في اللحظه التي تتحدث فيها كانت
اوقفوا جميع الاليات لانهم سمعوا على ما
يبدو صوت احد الناجين تحت الانقاض طلبوا
من الجميع الصمت وبالتالي هنالك امل
تحت هذه البنايه ان يكون هنالك ناجين نحن
هنا نتواجد منذ ساعه هذه نحن في حي مدمر
بالكامل ولا تزال هنالك عائلات تحت هذا
انا اخفض صوتي نايف لانهم طلبوا ذلك
يحاولوا تتبع صوت ياتي من تحت الانقاض
طبعا هنالك العائلات والان سيعني تشاهدها
على الكاميرا تنتظر مصير ذويهم تحت هذه
الانقاض هذا الحي المدمر بالكامل بنايتين
او ثلاث بنايات متلاصقه كانت سقطت بالكامل
انقذوا من انقذوا واخرجوا جثامين قتلى من
تحت الانقاض ولكن هنالك طبعا شاب تركي
التقيته للتو نجا هو من الزلزال خرج يعني
على قيد الحياه فيه بعض الاصابات في وجهه
ولكن شقيقه لا تزال تحت الانقاض وهنالك
عائله ايضا تركيه لديهم شاب وزوجته الحامل
ثمانيه اشهر في بطنها جنين عمره ثمانيه
اشهر في هذه البنايه لا يزال ينتظر حتى
هذه اللحظه
يعني العثور على على هؤلاء الاشخاص
وبالتالي نحن ننتظر هذا الحي طبعا كانت
عمليات الانقاذ لم تبدا فيه سوى يعني صباح
اليوم جاءت عمليات لانه كما تعلم الاحياء
الداخليه لهاتاي او ضواحي هاتاي انطاكيا
في هاتاي لم تدخلها فرق الانقاذ بعد هنالك
احياء كثيره لم تدخلها فرق الانقاذ لهم
يعطون الاولويه للبنايات التي يعتقدون
انها واضح تماما انها فيها ناجين
فيها ناجين انا ساتحدث الان يعني ساحاول
ان اتحدث عبر الشاشه
لاحدى النساء التي تنتظر مصير
لو سمحتي
الان في في صوت في امل بوجود ناجين يعني
وانت من لديك هنا ان تذكر لديك ابنتك
الحامل ثمانيه اشهر
وزوجها تحت هذه الانقاذ نعم نعم في المكان
الذي سمعوا فيه صوت صح
اللي يحاول الدخول اليه
ان شاء الله بده يطلع
ما في ريحه تموت ان شاء الله بده يطلعوا
طيبين يا ربي طب ايش شعورك الان بعد ما
سمعوا صوت اشخاص تحت الارض
[موسيقى]
عربتنا شوي مضايقه
ماذا شعرت حينما علمت انه في هنالك صوت
صوت
ان شاء الله